and with wind gusts reaching close to 60
miles per hour in some parts of town nv
energy was prepared in case of any
outages madison kim bros spoke with the
utility company heard how the weather
impacted people on the strip madison
continues our team coverage right near
las vegas boulevard
and brian and denise just you know i
kept my hair down just so you could see
the full effect of the wind going on
right now but we spoke to locals and
tourists all a good spirits about the
high winds many surprised at how strong
it got here though on the strip but not
letting it keep them from having a good
time here in las vegas
very surprised i was expecting it
no melting hot to be honest but you know
the breeze is brilliant for me i'm happy
high wind warning in effect monday
throughout the valley for gusts up to 70
miles per hour while many areas of town
saw 40 to 50 mile per hour winds it
didn't stop tourists at the fabulous las
vegas sign from stepping out although it
may have deterred their plans a little i
came from a weather advisory already in
california
half our power was out in town
so i was expecting to come to sun we're
actually really disappointed in this
weather because we came to take pictures
at the desert and we had to switch the
location because it was dangerous as for
long lines at the sign it was more of a
slow day due to the intense winds and
dust in the air this is the first time i
seen so so bad
okay
because sometimes you feel it at night
and that's no problem
when you're feeling during the day like
right now i better stay in the car for a
while scott kaufman with envy energy
shared that they knew these strong winds
were on their way and because of it they
planned accordingly we've got crews that
are holding over they're staying late
today
we're doubling up on some of our
troubleshooter assignments out in the
field so if something were to happen we
can get out there and respond as quickly
as we can
as for outages nv energy didn't see any
major areas hit by the strong winds
gusts will continue on for a couple more
hours but should settle down early
tomorrow morning reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now